Hello everybody. I think we can start the session.
So welcome here to the session on microbiota-host interactions in colorectal cancer
development and therapy. It's an honor for me to chair this
session.
And please may I ask you to first scan this QR code here on the screen.
Also the people here, because
then you can log in into the online interface.
There's also lots of people online that can also ask
questions during the sessions.
Okay, and then we can move on to the presentations.
Thank you.
Okay, so I'm Lars Verbeke. I'm from Belgium, from
Ghent. I'm affiliated to the Ghent University,
and VIB, Flemish Institute for Biotechnology.
And these are my disclosures.
And in this session, I will kick off with an introduction on this topic
and give some background on our work on pks E. coli.
And then we move on to two
outstanding and distinguished
scientists on this topic, Dr. Susan Bowman from University of Texas
MD Anderson Cancer Center, and Dr.
Wendy Garrett from Harvard Chan School of Public Health.
So let me just start by introducing microbiota-host
interactions in the colon under steady-state
conditions. So as you can see on this image here, the
human colon consists of around 10 million crypts
spread across around two square meters.
And you can see this organization with these invaginating crypts
with stem cells at the bottom.
And also the microbiota that are stained here by FISH probe in red.
They are physically segregated from the intestinal epithelium by this inner mucus
layer, which is around 50 microns in humans.
And this architecture and spatial organization is very important for
immune tolerance for normal tissue homeostasis.
But it's also important that, of course, the stem cells are shielded from
potential harmful substances in the gut lumen
from dietary or microbial origin.
And of course, there's
strong communication between these different compartments, the
microbiota, the intestinal epithelial cells, and underlying immune and
stromal cells to maintain homeostasis.
Now, it's important to mention that if there is genotoxic stress and
mutations occurring in the differentiated enterocytes and
other epithelial cells and surface-associated cells, this is usually
harmless because, of course, the entire intestinal epithelium is renewed every few
days, and these cells are anyhow shed and lost.
However, if mutations occur in the stem cells, they can
be fixed within the clonal crypt, and upon accumulation of sufficient
mutation, of course, this can lead to the development of
colorectal cancer.
Now on CRC epidemiology,
colorectal cancer is the third most common and deadly type of cancer in most
Western countries. And there's this alarming trend
that in people under the age of 50, there's increased
incidence of CRC development. And this is quite
disturbing because these people usually present with more advanced disease.
They're usually not picked up
or not enrolled in these national screening
platforms.
And this increasing evidence over the past decades really shows that this
is not a real genetic contribution, but mainly environmental and
lifestyle factors that strongly impact on CRC development, such
as unhealthy diets, so low in fiber, high in
processed foods, high in saturated fats,
a lot of red meat also. It's also associated to obesity
and sedentary lifestyle, alcohol use, and antibiotics, and all these
factors strongly impact on the intestinal
microbiota. Now, there's increasing evidence that the
microbiota actively contributes to colorectal cancer development
through various mechanisms, and they can be broadly subclassified
into four different mechanisms. The first mechanism
is through direct genotoxicity. So some bacteria produce
toxins that can directly induce mutations in the DNA, such as
pks E. coli, for instance, that produce colibactin, which I will talk about
later. The second mechanism is through metabolism of
dietary components, and they can be beneficial metabolites from the
fermentation of fibers,
generating short-chain fatty acids or tryptophan degradation
into indole derivatives that activate aryl hydrocarbon receptor.
These are pathways that will stabilize the intestinal barrier
and promote immune tolerance. On the other hand, diets rich
in red meat and saturated fats,
these will facilitate the production of harmful substances
like hydrogen sulfate, secondary bile acids,
N-nitroso compounds, nitrosamines, et cetera, that have a negative
impact on this barrier, the mucus barrier,
epithelial cell integrity, and will promote inflammation.
So a disturbance of this intestinal barrier can also facilitate bacterial
epithelial contact. This can also drive
inflammatory signaling through pattern recognition receptor activation, which can
promote the production of tumor-supportive cytokines such as IL-6,
IL-23, TGF-beta, IL-10, and so forth, and can also
stimulate the production of reactive oxygen and nitrogen species that can
further contribute to genotoxicity.
And then finally,
microbes can also influence antitumor immunity through various
mechanisms. So T-cell activation, exhaustion mechanisms,
modulation of checkpoint modulationModulation of CAR
T therapy response and so forth. So
through complex metabolic interactions.
And some of these mechanisms will be discussed in more detail during the session.
So
after my talk, we'll move on to
our two distinguished speaker here, Dr.
Susan Bowman, that will talk about intra-tumoral bacteria that reprogram
tumor cell states and therapy response in colorectal cancer. And then Dr.
Wendy Garrett at will talk about modulating the gut microbiome
to enhance anti-tumor immunity in colorectal cancer.
Now, I will start the session
by talking about colibactin-driven genotoxicity and how this depends
on epithelial adhesion.
So colibactin is a toxin that is produced by
several members of the Enterobacteriaceae family, like
E. coli,
and these pks+ E. coli harbor this pathogenicity island
that contain 19 genes that together contain all
enzymes required for generating this complex molecule here,
colibactin.
And this is a genotoxin. I will explain it a bit
better in the next slides, but it's important to know that in healthy individuals,
around 20% of people have pks E. coli in their
intestine. However, the prevalence increases in
people with intestinal inflammation, IBD, and even
increases to 60% in people with CRC.
So there's this clear tropism for the inflamed and
neoplastic gut. Although it is present in a large number of
people in healthy conditions.
Now, there was this landmark paper a couple of years ago by the Cleaver's lab, and
they show that if you inject intestinal organoids with these
pks E. coli consecutively, so you inject them, then you treat them with
antibiotics, you re-inject them over time for several weeks, and then you
sequence the DNA of clonal expanded
organoids. They found that there's a specific
mutational signature
linked to colibactin exposure in 80 rich DNA
sequences. So they found that colibactin through
this double cyclopropane warhead, can actually bind
adenine residues on opposing DNA strands and thereby
cross-link DNA, causing DNA damage responses that
will induce typical colibactin-associated mutational signatures
like the SBS88, so typical T to N mutations and the
ID18 or T deletions.
Now these mutational profiles are found in around one in eight
colorectal tumors, and they're specifically enriched in patients with
early onset CRC.
And also this colibactin exposure and these mutations can cause
mutations in typical tumor driver genes that have these 80 rich elements such
as APC.
Now, a recent paper by the Bascos lab nicely revealed
the structure of
active colibactin, which is a notoriously unstable molecule.
However, whenever it cross-links DNA, it turns into a stable
linked molecule.
And they could show that
this pseudosymmetrical structure here that you can see here
with colibactin with this double cyclopropane
electrophilic warheads can bind adenine residues
on opposing DNA strands, and it has this
concave structure where it nicely fits within the minor groove
of the DNA and there can cross-link DNA in these 80 rich
elements.
Now, my lab
mainly works with mouse models, and we study host microbe interactions
using germ-free gnotobiotic mouse technology.
So here you can see
our facility where we can house mice in complete sterile conditions.
But importantly, we have these regular black 6 experimental mice,
but we can also rederive our transgenic models in germ-free
conditions to actually verify whether a phenotype that develops
in colonized condition also replicates in germ-free conditions.
As you can see here through embryo transfer, so IVF generated embryos are
transplanted in pseudopregnant foster mothers.
And then we can also do targeted colonizations with bacteria of interest
to see which bacteria can actually contribute to colorectal cancer development,
and do specialized assays and do mouse colonoscopy,
and so forth.
Now, one of the mechanisms that we were
very interested in a couple of years ago
was this mechanism of EMT that is of course important in many
epithelial tumors. So where the epithelial cells
acquire more mesenchymal features.
And this allows cells to acquire more invasive capacity, so
it stimulates a tumor invasion and can also lead to metastasis later on.
There's a number of transcription factors that are important here, like ZEB1, ZEB2,
SNAI, SLUG. And we were interested in this ZEB2 transcription
factor, as we found that in patients.
So here you can see that in a normal colonic tissue,
ZEB2 positive cells are only found here in mesenchymal cells in the lamina
propria, but never in green epithelial cells.
However, we found that in around 50% of CRC samples,
we found also nuclear ZEB2 in intestinal
epithelial cells. These are all ZEB2 positive tumors.
This is a ZEB2 negative one. And others have also published the same.
So indicating that ZEB2 expression, ectopic expression in epithelial cells
is clinically relevant in a human setting.
So therefore, we generated transgenic mice that
expresses ZEB2 specifically in intestinal epithelial cells, and these
mice develop spontaneous invasive colorectal cancer over time, which we
can follow through mouse endoscopy.
And if we make cross-sections through the colon
and we fix the tissue and the mucus layer here, you can see that
inAgain, in wild-type mice, you have this nice physical
segregation in this inner mucus layer.
However, in the Zap2 transgenic mice, we have a disturbance of this mucus
layer. We have a barrier integrity loss and a facilitated bacterial
epithelial contact and invasion.
Now remarkably, germ-free Zap2 transgenic mice are completely protected,
so showing that colorectal cancer development in this model is
completely microbiota dependent.
So this gave us an interesting mouse model
to really study oncogenic specific oncobacteria in more
detail. And one of our favorite bugs is this pks E. coli.
So we compared the colonization of E.
coli strains in our Zap2 transgenic mouse model in colonized mice.
And we gavaged mice at six weeks of
age for four weeks and then sacrificed them for analysis.
So they were either colonized with 11G5, which is a CRC isolate,
pks positive strain, but also E. coli Nissle
1917 as a commensal control strain.
And we found that after four weeks of colonization,
only mice which were colonized with the 11G5 strain had severe
exacerbation of a phenotype where you could see already strong tissue
invasion in young mice,
but not with mice which were colonized with this E. coli Nissle strain.
So this work was really spearheaded by a talented postdoc in my lab,
Maud Jans here. And if you quantify
colon weight and his pathological scores, you can see that there's
clearly increased disease only upon colonization with
11G5.
Now we wanted to verify whether this is colibactin-dependent, so we did the same
experiment comparing 11G5 versus an
isogenic mutant strain that lacks one of these essential genes for colibactin
production, clbQ. So we see that only the
wild-type 11G5 strain is capable of promoting the CRC development
in this mouse model, not if the bacteria lack
clbQ. So it's clear that also here increase
in gamma-H2AX-positive cells only occurs in mice colonized
with 11G5, not if they lack this essential gene clbQ for
colibactin production.
Now it's important to mention that actually Nissle, E.
coli Nissle, is also a pks positive strain.
So we were surprised that although both are pks positive, only
11G5 promotes CRC development. So we wanted to figure out
whether actually both produce decent amounts of colibactin.
However, due to the unstable nature of colibactin, it's very hard to quantify
through mass spectrometry. So we quantified
NMA, which is a byproduct in the final maturation of pre-colibactin to
colibactin, as a proxy for colibactin
levels. And we found that although 11G5
does produce more colibactin compared to Nissle, Nissle does
produce
colibactin, as shown by NMA quantification here.
And this is quite alarming also because this
is a strain that is sold as a probiotic in Europe under the name
Mutaflor.
I must say it's a pretty good name for a mutagenic probiotic, but
I wouldn't advise you to take it maybe.
Nevertheless, it did not exacerbate CRC development in our
mouse model. But when we looked in more detail, and we stained for E.
coli
on colonic sections, and we found that E.
coli strongly associated to the intestinal epithelium here, only in the
11G5 colonized mice, not when they were colonized
with the Nissle strain. So that already indicated that probably
epithelial adhesive mechanisms play an important role here.
Now, bacteria and E. coli here has this
film switch mechanism, and it's a mechanism by which the bacteria can actually
switch from a more planktonic free-living
flagellated lifestyle to a more mucosal-associated lifestyle, which
lacks flagellum
and starts expressing a different pili that allows the bacteria to
bind to the epithelial surface. So they do so by a
phase variable promoter that can
switch orientation in the on or the off situation by specific
recombinases, and this allows the expression of different fimbriae like
the type one pili with terminal FimH
adhesins that bind D-mannose on N-glycoproteins,
but also F9 pili with terminal FimH adhesin that
binds
GalNAc and also T and TN antigens that are
typically enriched in inflamed and
dysplastic epithelium. And that is also a target
for Fusobacterium nucleatum, for instance.
Now we did the same. We used, again, isogenic mutant strains of
11G5 with either lacking FimH or FimH.
And we found that if you lack either of these adhesins,
you lack the capacity to bind cells, and you lack the capacity to invade
epithelial cells.
And also if you apply these strains in vivo, then only the wild type
11G5 exacerbates CRC development, not if you lose
FimH or FimH adhesins. Here
quantified.
And also again yeah, epithelial adhesion, as you can clearly see here in the
11G5 nicely binding epithelial cells.
This is lost when these bacteria lose FimH or
FimH.
Now we were interested to unravel a bit why perhaps there is
no functional redundancy that lacking either of these adhesins
is important for driving CRC development.
And we used recombinant lectin domains of these adhesins to stain tissue
to figure out where exactly these bacteria could be binding.
And we found that for FimH, there's a stronger staining here at the surface
epithelium, whereas for FimH, there is more
staining in the crypt cells.
Also the TF antigenIt was highly enriched in
green here in the crypt bottom, leading to this hypothesis, which we're
still
working on, that perhaps E. coli, upon Fim switching,
they can first bind through FimH on surface epithelial cells, but then crypt
invasion may be facilitated through FimLH interactions deeper
in the crypt, which allow colibactin production in close proximity to
stem cells, promoting
mutations in stem cells.
Now, we still didn't figure out why exactly Fim
11G5 strain is exacerbating CRC and not a Nissle strain.
So we compared sequences of FimH and FimLH, and in fact, the
FimLH adhesion was completely identical in sequence.
However, there were sequence variations within the FimH
sequence, and these amino acids were very important
to regulate and to switch the FimH into a
strong binding capacity, so in a high-affinity conformation.
So we wanted to confirm this, and we expressed these different
variants
on plasmid, and we transfected
them into the 11G5
or the Nissle that were deficient for the specific adhesion.
So we can actually exchange the different adhesion
forms into either 11G5 or Nissle. So when
we do this in 11G5, if you lose FimH, then you lose binding capacity.
If you actually
introduce this Nissle FimH, then you are not
able to bind to cells.
However, if you reintroduce the 11G5 FimH, then you can nicely
reestablish cellular binding capacity,
and this is replicated into genotoxicity.
So if you do gamma H2AX staining, then you see in the wild type 11G5, you see
strong genotoxicity. You lose it if there's no FimH.
If you introduce the Nissle FimH, then there's also no binding and no genotoxicity.
If you reintroduce the 11G5 FimH, then you
reintroduce genotoxicity. And we could also show the reverse.
If you express 11G5 FimH in Nissle, then you
increase binding and increase genotoxicity.
So finally, we did pharmacological targeting of FimH through
an available FimH blocker, Sibofimlock.
And there we could show that there's a nice dose-dependent decrease of bacterial
adhesion
with Sibofimlock, and this results in a dose-dependent reduction in
genotoxicity.
But also in vivo, if you apply this Sibofimlock by daily gavage in
mice that were gavaged with 11G5, then you see in the untreated
control mice, there's strong epithelial binding.
However, this is not the case if mice are treated with the
Sibofimlock compound. And also, of course, the CRC
development was reduced under Sibofimlock-treated
conditions.
So together, and to conclude here, we show that
PKS E. coli
binding and genotoxicity strongly depend on these FimH and FimLH
adhesins. This allows bacteria to bind specific glycan proteins,
glycan targets on intestinal epithelial cells.
And this allows production of this highly unstable colibactin molecule in
close proximity to host DNA that allows translocation
to the nucleus and binding to these AT-rich elements in the DNA and cause
mutations.
So it's really these
small variations in FimH that can determine a
high-affinity binding or a strong binder or a weak binder that
determines
the genotoxic potential.
And hereby, I want to acknowledge the people that contributed to this work.
So definitely Mot Janz here as first author together
with Magdalena Kolata in Han Remaut's lab, an expert
in adhesin biology.
Also, Ilian Iliev from Weill Cornell contributed to this
work. Other local collaborators and the germ-free
facility and all the funding agencies.
So with that, I'm happy to take questions before we move on to the next speaker.
That was really brilliant. Thanks.
Sort of tangentially, but I can't get it out of my head. Why is E.
coli Nissle a good probiotic if it
has this big fitness hit, I assume-
Mm-hmm
... for not being able to adhere? Can you detect it
after giving it to the mice for a while, or does it just pass through the
colon without colonizing?
Well, it does stably colonize also Nissle, so it doesn't seem to be
dependent on this binding capacity.
But it is remarkable that it is sold as a probiotic indeed.
I even notified this European agencies, and they were actually
not willing to take action because they thought that actually the benefits or the
proven benefits outweigh the potential
negative parts. And yeah, a ClbQ knockout Nissle would be
better, but in Europe, you don't want GMO, so that's also not an
option.
So thank you, Ernst, for a good talk.
And
after binding to the epithelial cells, how the colibactin
inducing go into the cell? Is that through
the diffusion or some specific receptors in the epithelial
cells?
Yeah, that's also a very good question, and that has not yet been resolved.
So it's really unclear how migration of colibactin to the
nucleus really occurs. That is
unclear whether it's really passive diffusion or there's some kind of
transport mechanism or
perhaps also EV-mediated transport.
So this is not clear.
Okay. Thank you.
Very nice talk. So I sort of have a question.
The first is, is this epithelial binding super
conserved?Across all the endobacteria
nucleases like casabella or anything, have you tested that
in the different bacteria? And
second thing is since the regular mice, white type mice, and human, they all
usually have a high mucosal layer.
Do you have any hypothesis on how the
colibactin-producing bacteria regularly promote
the cancer progression in people?
Yeah. Two interesting questions.
So first, we haven't really profiled adhesive
mechanisms of multiple enterobacteria CI. We focus on E.
coli, but we're doing more research now into
really comparing
FimH variants in tumor versus healthy tissue from
patients. We do have some preliminary data that there seems to be some
niche partitioning, so that it can be an enrichment for these
high-affinity binders at the tumor site.
And then, as you say, in a wild type normal healthy
epithelium with a normal mucus layer, this is probably sufficient to protect
you from colibactin insults.
However, there are various
conditions where the mucus layer can be eroded, where the
glycan
docking sites for these E. coli can be accessible,
like under
low fiber conditions, for instance, under antibiotic treatments,
during inflammation. So these are all conditions.
So perhaps also in early life, because it's known that colibactin
is particularly inducing mutations in early life.
In the neonatal,
maybe in the gut that has not sufficiently established this tight inner
mucus layer. These may be vulnerable periods where you can
accumulate
mutations early in life that can then sensitize you perhaps to CRC
development later on in life.
Excellent talk.
Mine is just a curiosity because I was wondering which are the patient
suitable for this kind of therapy.
If the tumor is already present,
you could not have any effect.
Yeah.
So which are the kind of a patient that you think are suitable
for this?
Yeah, so that's also a very good point.
So there's, like I said, you could have early in life already or
throughout life, this typical hit-and-run mechanism where you can have
binding events and genotoxicity, which you accumulate, but also during
an established tumor, they can also still be enriched
E. coli presence that can still exacerbate tumor
development. So,
if you would have a really good therapy against pks E.
coli,
you could figure out which people should we treat.
Perhaps maybe mothers that have pks E.
coli before they deliver the baby to prevent maternal transmission early in
life, or
IBD patients, for instance, which also have enriched
pks E. coli presence or FAP patients that will
inevitably develop tumors. But of course, they are very prone to
loss of function and loss of heterozygosity of APC that is a typical
target of colibactin. So there's quite a range of
people that could be suitable for these
colibactin-targeted therapies.
Can I just ask one question? Sorry, a quick question, Jens.
So it is quite alarming with the E. coli nissle.
It's producing colibactin, but the fact that it's not adhering to the
epithelial cells gives us some relief.
Mm-hmm.
But I suppose the challenge is in a patient, it's never just one
microbe.
Mm-hmm.
Do you think that if somebody is taking E.
coli nissle as a supplement, that if you've a microbe in your gut
that can adhere to epithelial cells, but it's not producing colibactin, but if
it's co-aggregating with nissle-
Yeah. Mm-hmm
... do you think it could have that toxigenic effect that you're seeing
with binding even though it's indirectly taking advantage of another
co-occurring microbe?
Yeah, that's a very interesting point.
If you would have other bacteria that can also destabilize the barrier or erode the
mucus layer-
Or diet as polysorbate 80 breaking down-
Yeah
... mucus-
Yeah. Definitely
... in our gut.
Indeed, dietary factors that can erode the mucus layer in presence of
a colibactin producer-
Mm-hmm
... can indeed be damaging in this case, probably.
Okay. Thank you.
Good points. Yeah.
Okay, thank you. So if there's no further questions, then we move on
to the next speakers, and if I'm not mistaking, this will be Dr.
Wendy Garrett from Harvard Med School.
Thank you.
Thank the organizers for inviting me, and Jens for the-- Lars for the
introduction.
Here are my disclosures.
So we heard about sort of the negative sides of the microbiome, but it's not all
bad. And so maybe this will spark a little bit of hope around
metabolites that members of the microbiota make that promote
anti-tumor immunity.
So I'm going to tell you two stories.
One's an accepted manuscript, just an excerpt from that, and then one story that's
in revision.
So
we have a philosophy that we take, and it's approach that I hope I can
maybe endorse that you all will take on, and that's how we can leverage
available human microbiome data and mouse models to
understand at the mechanistic level microbial
contributions to colorectal cancer, whether they enhance
susceptibility or resistance. And this project over the years has been
led by three different postdoctoral fellows, all who have now moved on to
independent positions. And the narrative flow will flip-flop a little bit
between observations in humans and
mice.So in 2018,
three fabulous studies came out, and you probably are familiar
with them if you are in this IO microbiome space.
One was from MD Anderson, led by Jennifer Wargo.
One was from University of Chicago, led by the Gajewski Lab.
And a third came from France, Gustave Roussy, led by Laurence
Zitvogel. And what they all found were different
taxa, different microbes that patients harbored that
distinguished individuals that went on to become
non-responders or responders to anti-PD-1.
But they all found something different, and that sort of created a
psychic itch in my lab. And so we thought
maybe we need to take a step back and not look at
taxa, but look in these data sets and look at the metabolic
pathways, because maybe that was a unifying feature that could
explain what in the microbiome supported anti-tumor
immunity. So time has passed over the last eight years,
and now there are at least 17 IO studies,
most using anti-PD-1. And so we looked at the most
upregulated MetaSeq pathways, metabolic pathways
enriched in responders versus non-responders.
And we all see something different, maybe when we look at metabolic pathways.
Maybe you see one carbon metabolism, maybe you just see methionine and
cysteine.
And so we're very curious in how we can
promote anti-tumor immunity in colon cancer.
And as many or most of you know, the vast majority of colon cancer
is mismatch repair proficient, meaning that those
individuals won't respond to the most IOs that are on the market.
And so we looked at metabolic pathways in stool
in normal, and normal means not colon cancer, not
adenoma individuals, versus individuals with colon cancer.
And we looked in that in conjunction with individuals that
were responders versus non-responders to different IO
therapeutics. So this is colon cancer.
This is not colon cancer. So lung, renal,
melanoma, hepatocellular carcinoma.
And if you look at the pattern of this data, it's really remarkable that there's
nothing in this quadrant. And so we've done a lot of analyses making sure that that
holds up, taking out stage I, stage II, stage III, stage IV
colon cancer and seeing if it changes the shape of the data.
But again, what we saw was these pathways pop up again in
individuals that lack colon cancer and individuals
that were responsive to IO therapy.
So there are a million ways you could take that data and run with
it, and I'm just telling you what we did with it.
And what we did is we talked to nutritional epidemiologists, and we
asked how much methionine and cysteine do regular
people in the United States consume.
And we were interested in edge cases of normal.
And that means people that are on the high end of normal consumption and
people that are on the low end of normal consumption.
And high for methionine and cysteine would not lead to
hyperhomocysteinemia, and low is in
no way, shape, or form methionine restriction, which is
absolutely fascinating, but not at all what this study has to do with.
And so we then created a diet in mice, which we then could
recapitulate with subtle dietary changes in
people or supplementation. And these are the
amounts from baseline that these two diets differ in the
mice. And the reason I put those values up there is if you look
at papers and they supplement cysteine or methionine,
it is usually 40 times the amount I'm showing you here,
and it is usually 20 times less, usually, if you are a
geek about diet. Okay. So these are the kinds of
experiments that PIs love, because if there was any difference
between the high or low diet, I would be excited.
Sort of the winner-winner kinds of experiments in lab.
And we started with a very simple model, a flawed
model. As an oncologist, I can tell you I never see colon cancer in the
flank. And if any of you have, please come up to me after.
And the other problem with this model, or not problem, but just observation,
is this is mismatch repair defective. It's MC38.
But we saw a difference in the diet.
The tumors were bigger in the low and smaller in the high.
Now, are they really bigger? They are actually
smaller with the high. And how do I know that?
Because we compared it to the regular diet.
And you might ask, do the mice not like the high diet, or do they eat
less or whatever? No, they eat the same amount, and we measured their metabolic
activity. Now, at the end of the day, you can see the tumors and
the lovely pictures, and you can see the weights.
But this is not very good for modeling what we wanted to model, so we
switched to the Cdx2-Cre by floxed ApcMin mouse.
These experiments are far longer.
They make the postdocs far less happy and the students far less happy.
But what we saw in the high diet is a lower number of
adenocarcinoma events. And of course, there are more than
one lesion in the mouse models, unlike people.
The lesion diameter when we saw lesions were smaller, and the tumor weight was
less. So that was interesting to us.
And because we are microbiome scientists, we can't help ourselves but
look in the microbiome. And what we saw was rather remarkable to us.
We saw one taxa, and this is what we wanted to get away from, but one taxa that
bloomed, and that taxon is called Musasprillum
schatlerae. And what I'm showing you over here is that it
really seems to have this interesting relationship with diet.
It blooms in the high sulfur amino acid diet, whether you are a
Cdx2-Cre by floxed ApcMin mouse, whether you are an
SPF mouse that was unfortunate to receive MC38 in your flank,
or if you are mice harboring the altered Schatla flora, which is a consortium
of eight bugs, of which Musasprillum schatlerae is
one.But what about people?
So if there is a stool metagenome that is publicly available,
I have looked at it and looked for Muscasprillum schadleri, and you're not going to
find reliable reads in the stool.
But where you will find reads is in the mucosa.
So if you look at tissue-based studies where they have done
profiling, you will find Muscasprillum schadleri in normal tissue,
adenoma, but not in adenocarcinoma.
So why? Well, like its name, Muscasprillum
schadleri loves to live in the mucus.
And here I'm showing you some fluorescence in situ hybridization, and the
pink is the M. schadleri, and the green is
mucin 2. Mucins in the mucus layer are
very important, as we heard from the prior talk from Lars.
And what we found was that
the mucus layer is thicker, and there are more M.
schadleri in response to the high sulfur amino acid diet
versus the low. So why is that? So diet could
affect the proliferation of goblet cells, and you could have more goblet
cells and more mucus. That was not the case.
But you did have more and thicker
inner mucus layer. And this was truly driven
by the diet and not by the microbiota, because, like
Lars, we use a gnotobiotic facility where we can
play with or toggle that variable of
what microbes are there.
So I'll tell you,
we looked for many years to figure out what was the it factor of
why the mucus was thicker.
It's not stickier for M. schadleri. It's not because they're sulfur mucins.
It's very simple. M. schadleri does not eat mucus,
and many mucus-associated microbes do.
So that's why it's thicker. So as any card-carrying
immunologist will do when they're thinking about anti-tumor immunity, what do
they look for? They look for the all-important CD8 positive T
cell. And in this high diet, we saw more CD8
positive T cells, and they made more gamma,
not statistically significant. They made more granzyme B.
They were less activated or exhausted.
But that's not really interesting because we know those cells are important
for human colon cancer and just about all human cancers.
So what is upstream of the CD8 positive T cell?
Can this diet and bug link get us there?
And so what did we look at next? We looked at dendritic cells.
And what was enriched in the tumor-draining lymph node was the
CDC1 dendritic cell that cross-presents to the
CD8 positive T cell, and diet increased that.
And so now we wanted to shore up that link.
And the way we shored up that link was using different
mouse models. And so for the
aficionados or people that love CDC1s, there are a couple ways to
approach that. One is the Batf3
knockout mouse, and we crossed that to the Cdx2-Cre by floxed
Apc mouse, and we could toggle our low versus high sulfur amino
acid diet and look for M. schadleri.
And indeed, if you mess up the CDC1
compartment, even if mucin is there, you lose the
effect of diet.
One tool is never enough. And so next we use the
Zbt46 diphtheria toxin mice, made bone marrow
chimeras, I can explain why if you're interested, with the Apc
mice, and then deleted or treated those mice with
diphtheria toxin. And so we removed the CDC1 compartment.
And these experiments are labor-intensive and long, but they
reassured us that there is something important or something going on with M.
schadleri and CDC1 dendritic cells.
So as anyone that knows and loves CDC1 dendritic cells, what do
they have on their cell surface? They have XCR1 on their cell
surface. And what that means is that they find
XCL1, or lymphotactin, very chemoattractive.
It's a wonderful stimulant for the CDC1.
And I won't show you any single-cell data.
It's in the manuscript that will be published at some point soon.
But what we did is we neutralized the XCL1.
And in so doing, we found that that was an important piece in
this puzzle of M. schadleri, high sulfur amino acid diet,
and CDC1s. And so as an immunologist, the next question you
ask is who makes it? And if you read the textbooks, there is an
answer, and the answer is NK cells.
But the textbooks aren't always exactly right.
And what we found in these studies from these mice
was that the NKT cells were making that all-important
XCL1.
And not a lot of people think about NKT cells
or innate T cells overall in anti-tumor immunity.
There's some posters here that are getting on that, and I think we should
definitely think more about innate T cell populations.
And there is a wonderful reagent that Mitch Kronenberg
from the San Diego area generated many years ago, and that is a
neutralizing antibody. And what that antibody enabled us to
do was to interrogate or pull apart this diet M.
schadleri interaction. And what we found was that NKT
cells are very, very important for this diet M.
schadleri link. And so the next thing we did is begin to
fractionate what M. schadleri is doing.
And whether you are a mouse NKT cell or a human NKT
cell, Muscasprillum schadleri and a conditioned
media thereof, especially the organic fraction,
stimulates the NKT cell to make more
XCL1.Now, I wish I could show you the
phospholipids today that Mucispirillum schadlerii
is making. It is not just one. The microbial world is very
complex. Mucispirillum schadlerii makes many.
What I can tell you is those phospholipids do not
bind the all-important antigen-presenting molecule for the
NKT cell CD1d. So they stimulate the NKT
cell independent of the molecule that stimulates its T
cell receptor.
So the microbiome and diet interactions are incredibly
complex. You have to be in for the long haul if you're going to pull that apart.
But in this first story, what I told you is
subtle modulations of dietary cysteine and methionine
intake can increase the mucus layer, and I think all of us would
agree that that is good. What that does, for reasons that we
don't still understand, is create a niche for a microbe that
exists in people, in mice, called Mucispirillum schadlerii.
That microbe makes phospholipids that stimulate
NKT cells to make more XCL1, which then
activate the CDC1 to be more potent in activating CD8
positive T cells and driving more productive antitumor
immunity.
So phospholipids from your microbiome are important.
This next story has been led by Slater Clay in the lab, a very
talented postdoc who's on the job market, and is about
acetoacetate and how it suppresses colon cancer
progression via an MHC-related
protein or MR1 mucosal-associated invariant
T cell axis. And it will move between people
and mice and end up in the test tube for some chemistry.
So you've all heard about ketogenic diet.
I wonder how many of you are actually on it.
I can tell you compliance is extremely difficult in patient
populations, especially cancer patient populations.
But what ketogenic diet does is it leads to the
generation of ketone bodies. There are three.
Acetone, I don't feel like drinking that,
acetoacetate, and beta-hydroxybutyrate.
And there are a lot of wonderful papers that have explored how it may
promote antitumor immunity, which may be of use for colon
cancer and other malignancies. The vast majority of
studies have focused on beta-hydroxybutyrate.
You can get onto any online search engine and buy
beta-hydroxybutyrate for your personal consumption.
I am in no way endorsing that. There are relatively fewer studies on
acetoacetate, and if you're not into keto diet, there are other
ways you can make these ketone bodies increase in your
body. You could fast, and most of us enjoy eating,
or you could do extreme exercise. What we wanted to come up with was
maybe a way to provision exogenous ketones, in particular this
acetoacetate, and see if it had any antitumor
immune functions like beta-hydroxybutyrate.
And so the first thing that we played with was a little bit of chemistry.
The challenge was how to make a stable form of
acetoacetate and an easy way to give it in the lab, so it wouldn't
make the postdocs and students
overworked, if you will. And what we did was we esterified it
and used this ethyl acetoacetate.
And why that was fun and why I'll show you it's very gratifying, is
it's an FDA-approved food flavoring, so
maybe not all of these food flavorings are bad, and this one tastes like green
apples or strawberry. So if you've ever had a candy or
something with that flavoring, you might have consumed ethyl
acetoacetate.
So the first thing we did is we gave it to our Cdx2-Cre or floxed
ApcMin mice, and we found that the serum
ACAC levels increased, but not
beta-hydroxybutyrate. That's still a little puzzle because we all have
enzymes that interconvert those.
The ACAC did not increase in the colon tissue, but it did
increase in the tumor, and in the feces.
But what we all want to know is did it do anything for tumor multiplicity?
And so this first graph, for all the mouse modelers in the audience, I want to show
you, because each circle is an experiment.
And so we are looking at experiments over a three-year period
to address issues of reproducibility and robustness over time.
And in the next graph, we're looking at individual mice
and tumor number, and in the last, individual number and tumor weight,
and then the histopathology, aberrant crypt foci, adenoma, and
adenocarcinoma. And ethyl acetoacetate or EAA
reduces the number of adenocarcinomas.
One model is never enough. We use the ApcMin model and give it just a
touch of DSS, so our mice develop colonic tumors, and
we found that EAA worked there. And we also
use orthotopic injection, and here I'm showing you data from Apc,
K-ras, and T53 tumor organoids, and it reduced tumor weight there
as well.
So what does it do? We did sort of the reflexive move that many of us engage in.
We took those tumors from the Apc mice and performed single-cell
RNA-seq. And while sort of a high-level analysis
wasn't revealing, when we really pulled apart the lymphocyte populations,
we found one
population that was statistically significantly enriched, and those were
the mucosal-associated invariant T cells, or MAIT cells.
So what are MAIT cells? I teach immunology, and most of our graduate
students and undergrads don't know about them.
They are innate-like T cells that recognize bacterial and
fungal microbial metabolites and vitamin B2-like
derivatives. They populate human barrier sites,
skin, oropharynx, intestine, respiratory tract, urogenital tract,
blood, and liver. They are much more easy to study
in humans. Mice usually don't have that many of them.
Most of the research has focused on their roles in host defense,
but we have our fingers crossed for more antitumor immunity
work in the future.CAR MAITs and maybe picking up on these
ideas. So what's kind of remarkable about the MAITs is these MAIT
cells from mice that received ethyl acetoacetate had more gamma than
any other lymphocyte in the tumor microenvironment, and also more
granzyme B and perforin. And it wasn't only single-cell seq data.
I'm showing you data from individual mice and individual mouse tumors, where by
flow cytometry we measured granzyme B and interferon gamma as
well. So now we wanted to understand why, and so
we pivot to using a tool that enables us
to take away the MAIT cells. And genetic
background is important for studying MAIT cells in mice, and we used
MR1 knockout, that's the antigen-presenting molecule that binds
the T cell receptor for the MAIT cell, or
sufficient MR1 mice. And we found out that our
phenotypes using this orthotopic model of EAA were
dependent on antigen-presenting cells expressing that
MR1 molecule.
So I want to tell you a little bit briefly about the chemistry.
One wonderful thing is this metabolite, all
humans have, whether they have cancer or not, and it is very
important. Lots of microbes make it.
Microbes that live in all human guts, microbes that live on the
skin, and even microbes that can live in tumors.
And it reacts with methylglyoxal or glyoxal, and methylglyoxal is a
byproduct of glycolysis, of course, and it generates this beautiful
molecule. And this molecule is beautiful because it sits in the
pocket of the MR1 molecule, and it
activates MAIT cells. It's not the only thing that sits in that
MR1 molecule, but there are beautiful immunological attachmer tools that enable us
to study it.
And so the other beautiful thing about MAIT cells
and MR1, is how similar they are between
humans and mice if you're a modeler.
Unlike MHC class I and class II, these
molecules are so similar that you can do experiments in
humans and mice and use similar reagents.
And so what I'm showing you here is data on MAIT cells from human peripheral blood
mononuclear cells. And what we're asking here is if the
acetoacetate can expand MAIT cells in
culture, and it can, when you provide this microbial metabolite that
all people have. And what I'm showing you here is it's dependent
upon MR1. Now, why am I telling you about MR1?
Because peripheral blood mononuclear cell cultures have
antigen-presenting cells and then the MAIT cells.
So it's a way to study the dependency, and the expansion, and all this
immunology in the test tube from people.
So the next thing I'm showing you is, so what? So there are more MAIT cells.
We always want to know about what they're doing functionally.
And here I'm showing you data from human colon cancer cells, or Caco-2s,
and by culturing the MAIT cells with
acetoacetate,
you get more potent killing of the Caco-2 cells.
And so now I'm asking why.
And it looks like the ethyl acetoacetate acts on the
cancer cell or the antigen-presenting cell, and it puts more of that
important antigen-presenting cell, MR1, on the cell
surface. And interestingly, it's not the dendritic cell, which we all
believe is the preeminent antigen-presenting cell.
It's actually monocytes that are probably mediating this
antigen presentation
action or activation of MAIT cells, as well as tumor cells.
And the other little tidbit I'll point out is we all worry as cancer
immunologists about downregulation of MHC class
I on the tumor cell. But in this case, it doesn't seem like it's the
case.
And so not only did this hold for human cells, but it
held for our mouse cells as well in terms of
monocytes expressing a lot. And now I'll take you to
the test tube, where if you do a lot of chemistry or mass spectrometry,
you'll know this is kind of tricky.
We wanted to understand what acetoacetate was
doing. And we know that there is a chemical reaction that
immunologists exploit to generate this important molecule that
sits in the groove of the MR1 molecule.
And so what we wanted to ask is if acetoacetate, an
exogenous ketone or endogenous, interacted with a
microbial metabolite to generate the molecule that
sits in the groove of the antigen-presenting molecule.
And this is a very in vitro experiment.
We're throwing 5-ARU in the test tube. We're throwing the acetoacetate.
And yes, in the test tube, we can generate this
molecule that it needs to meet up with an
MR1, and then the MR1 antigen-presenting cell will get to the cell surface.
This was a reach experiment, and as a PI, you got to believe in your people because
I never thought this experiment was going to work.
And here we have a peripheral blood mononuclear cell culture where we gave the
microbial metabolite 5-ARU, we gave the acetoacetate,
and what we found is that you do indeed generate the
5-OPRU within cells as well as the media.
And now this is a bit of very geeky chemistry to actually
get at the question of whether acetoacetate forms
methylglyoxal that is needed for this reaction.
And so what we did, with the help of the brilliant chemist, John Clardy,
who's one of my colleagues, is see if acetoacetate formed
methylglyoxal. And this is a tricky experiment because of the
rederivatization chemistry involved.
And what we found is if you have atmospheric oxygen, just a
little bit of oxygen,
acetoacetate does indeed form methylglyoxal.
So you can move from people, an idea about diet, to preclinical models,
and back to the test tube to understand antigen presentation for
anti-tumor immunity. And this is already an
FDA-approved flavoring. So it's really cool to think about how we might be able
to deploy this and this MR1 MAIT cell access to help people and
enhance their anti-tumor immunity.
With that, I want to thank you for your attention and time, the patients and
healthy volunteers in our cohorts, and my wonderful collaborators. Thank you.
Maybe I can start the discussion on your first
project. So how exactly was the mucus layer
thickening stimulated by the bacterium?
So, it's not stimulated by bacteria because we see a thickened
mucus layer even in germ-free mice.
As you know, at baseline, the mucus layer is thinner, but it increased with a high
sulfur amino acid diet.
So we're not exactly sure. We know there are not more goblet cells,
but definitely the layer is thickened.
And we also know it's not increasing secretion.
For some reason that is independent of MUC2
deployed mucus being stickier for M. shatleri.
M. shatleri can compete out other bugs like B.
theta or Akkermansia muciniphila and gains a foothold.
Okay.
And they're not more sulfomucins either.
We've investigated those, too.
Maybe the hydration of mucus could be expanded and causes
thickening.
Maybe. We've worked with some mucin glycobiologists and haven't
unpacked, pun intended, what it is.
Interesting.
Over there.
Very nice talk, Dr. Garrett. I have two questions.
So the first is, how does exactly the NKT cells or
MAIT cells have anti-tumor function?
Is that through the TCR signaling or it's more like NK cells through the death
ligands or T cells as well? And second question would be,
have you ever tested the MAIT cell function mediated by the metabolomics
in other model, like lung cancer, liver cancer, which MAIT cells are as...
Thank you so much.
Sure. So the MAIT cells and the NKT cells
can directly kill the cancer cells. Okay.
So I hope that answers question number one.
And gamma delta T cells can do that, too, but they're a
beautiful number, and innate lymphoid cells.
There are lots of innate T cell populations, NK, NKT, gamma
delta, MAIT, MR1-restricted T cells that are capable of
killing tumor cells,
period, end stop. And so we, I think, become so fixated maybe on
CD8s and CD4 that I hope the field opens their eyes.
And to open your eyes, only look at a single-cell RNA-seq data set of a primary
tumor. Now, those cells can fluctuate in cell states, and they have
to be making the right kinds of cytokines and
hole-punching molecules to be effective anti-tumor
immune cells. And
you also asked me a question about MAIT cells, I think.
Yeah. So the second question would be, I
know that you also do lymphoma in colorectal cancer.
We have not looked at
cutaneous T cell lymphomas yet. We haven't looked at melanoma yet.
We haven't looked at lung. We're very interested in
endometrial cancer and urogenital cancers as well, but that's work in
progress. And I wouldn't be surprised if they had a role.
Okay, if there's no further questions, then we move on to the last speaker of this
session, Dr. Susan Bowman.
Thank you, Lars.
Okay, I'm just waiting for my slides. Perfect.
So good afternoon, everyone. It's a pleasure to be here with you today.
And I'm going to shift gears slightly.
I'm going to talk about intratumoral microbes and how they can
modulate tumor cell states and impact therapy.
And since I began working in this field over a decade ago, we've really shifted our
focus from initially profiling whether or not there are actually even microbes
that are residing in tumors, to now trying to understand what they're
doing once they're within the tumors.
And today, I'm going to show you some of our work, along with work from across the
field, on understanding how these microbes modulate their
infected tumor niche and how that, in turn, will impact
patient treatment responses.
So as you all know, we've about 39 trillion microbes that are living
on and within our bodies, and most of this is within our
gastrointestinal tract. So in particular, our
colorectum, so about 95%. And it's here where these microbes, they
really set the stage for dynamic interactions in human health and
disease processes. That includes cancer.
And it really was enabled by the next generation
sequencing era and the availability of the human
reference genome that propelled this field forward, because
groups could begin to ask, what does the microbiome look like, or the
microbial profiles in human tissue?
How does that compare in cancer versus adjacent normal tissue?
And when groups began profiling this back in about 2010,
2011, they started observing that there were specific taxa
enriched within tumor tissue compared to adjacent normal tissue.
And surprisingly, many of these microbes were typically
oral microbes. They should've been just present in the mouth, but when tumors were
rising in the lower GI tract, these oral microbes were
infiltrating the tumor tissue, or at least associated with the
tissue based upon sequencing approaches.
So it raised a couple of questions.
How are these oral microbes, like Fusobacterium, actually getting to
colorectal tumors? And what were they doing once they
arrived at that tumor?And I think
big question after the initial discovery studies that
identified enrichment of particular microbes in colorectal tumors
was whether this spanned across patient populations.
And this led to more epidemiological studies,
population-based studies, and I would say this has been largely spearheaded
by Shuji Ogino at the Dana-Farber. Many of us have collaborated with him.
But he looked at data from the Nurses' Health Study, the Physician Follow-up Study,
so very large, prospective patient cohorts where
individuals were followed over time prior to the development of cancer.
They looked at diet. They looked at behavioral aspects.
And then in those individuals that did develop tumors, he
profiled the amount of Fusobacterium through qPCR, so
comparing tumors that had relatively high, intermediate,
or low levels of Fusobacterium. And what these studies saw
was a correlation between the amount of this
microbe in the tumor and patient clinical and
molecular data. So enrichment of Fusobacterium in
right-sided colon cancer is associated with certain types of mutations like
BRAF V600E, MSI high tumors.
But also in patients that had a Western diet,
they were more likely to have Fusobacterium-positive colorectal
tumors. And why this mattered was because patients that had
high levels of Fusobacterium in their tumor, they had poorer overall
survival. And we're still trying to figure out why exactly that
is. But the importance here was that it showed us this wasn't just a
random association, that it was linked.
Its presence was linked with biology of colorectal
cancer. And that pushed us to really ask what's happening in
these patient tumors when this microbe is present.
But before I jump in and start talking about Fusobacterium in more detail,
I did want to highlight many studies, very important functional
studies over the last several years that have demonstrated a role for
microbes in cancer initiation, progression, and treatment response.
And this by no means is a comprehensive list.
But as we just heard from Lars, we heard about this pks positive E.
coli and colibactin directly inducing mutational signatures.
And I do want to give a shout-out to Christian Jobin, who I would say is really the
godfather of pks positive E. coli and linking it to colorectal cancer and really
bringing it to our attention. But in addition to the pks
positive E. coli, there are many other taxa that are now emerging as
having genotoxic roles in helping initiate
colorectal cancer. This includes recent work from
Noah Palm's group, where they looked at Morganella morganii, as
we've just heard from Lars, who described this work.
We've also seen recent work come out from Cindy Sears and Julia Drew, who's looking
at Citophyl and this microbe that is present in
colorectal tumors but also present in the mucosal slurries from
tumors from patients with colorectal cancer and showed in mouse models that this
could increase tumor genesis. And again, work from Christian
Jobin's group that is looking at Campylobacter jejuni, this
microbe is an organism that's associated with food poisoning.
It is a pathogen in the gut, and it has a cytolysin V descending
toxin that has been shown through this work to induce or
increase the number of tumors in mouse models.
And more recently, work that was published, a beautiful study in cell
host microbe demonstrating the role of Campylobacter in colorectal
cancer metastases.
And in addition, as we've just talked about as well, these microbes are never in
isolation. It's never just a single microbe present in the tumor.
They occur in communities. And Cindy Sears, a while back, looked at
synergistic effects between pks positive E.
coli and enterotoxigenic Bacteroides fragilis in patients with
familiar adenomatous polyposis, demonstrating that they work together to
enhance mutations within the colonic
epithelial cells. So they had a synergistic effect.
There's been studies demonstrating the indirect ability of microbes to contribute
to chemoresistance by changing cell states, for example,
inducing autophagy that led to resistance to
chemotherapeutics and also directly contributing to
chemotherapy. So work from my group have demonstrated that
50% of the patients we assessed with colorectal cancer harbored
bacteria that could metabolize 5-fluorouracil into an
inactive form. And that work was also assessed
by
Peter Turnbaugh's group that really shed light on the preTA operon and the presence
of this preTA operon in our gut microbes, metabolizing routine
chemotherapeutic drugs into an inactive form.
And then prior work from my work as a postdoc, we demonstrated
that these microbes are not just present in the primary colorectal tumors, but they
persist with the cancer as it spreads in distance like disease and
metastases. And when we looked at the microbial communities in the
metastatic colorectal cancer, they resembled more the primary tumor than
liver metastases, so demonstrating that these microbes are an intrinsic
component of the tumor microenvironment.
And when we think about the tumor microenvironment, we'll often think about the
cancer cell itself. What are the mutations that are present?
Are they driving the cancer? Can we target them for treatment?
But we know that within these patient tumors, these cancer epithelial
cells are surrounded by a network of nonmalignant cells.
We've got infiltrating immune cells that we've just heard about, and they can have
pro or antitumorigenic effects. We've endothelial cells. We've fibroblasts.
And now, at least in colorectal cancers, we have this
tumor-infiltrating microbial component.
So an area that my group is particularly interested in is understanding what
happens when these microbes enter the tumor.
Where are they localized? What are the human cells they're interacting with?
And importantly, what are the consequences of these host
microbial interactions?And here I'm showing you
a video of a patient's colon adenocarcinoma tumor.
And we've carried out RNA scope on this tumor where Fusobacterium is
red, and we have Eubacteria as a cyan color.
So as we're looking around this tissue, you can see that these microbes are not
just present on the surface of the tumor.
They have infiltrated, invaded the tumor tissue.
But they're very focally localized. They're not distributed everywhere.
So this tells us that once the microbes have infiltrated the
tissue, they are not universally present across the tumor tissue, but they
have a heterogeneous distribution. So that's interesting.
What allows the microbes to invade, survive, persist in one
region of the tumor, but completely are absent from another region of the
same patient's tumor?
And to understand this, we applied a range of approaches, and we were
taking hold of the spatial biology era.
And even these technologies that I'm showing you right now are pretty much
outdated, but this was 10x Visium spatial transcriptomics.
And we use computational subtraction approaches that I had mentioned
earlier that had actually led to the discovery of microbes in
tumor tissue. But here, when we applied this approach, we
wanted to assess what are the microbial taxa within the
tumor tissue, could we map them in situ directly in the
patient's
tumor tissue without losing that spatial biology.
And this was an adaption of 10x Visium spatial transcriptomics, and I would say
it's very important to always include an orthogonal approach whenever you're
assessing something, especially with sequencing technologies.
So we would always carry out RNA scope on a sequential section, and
as a sanity check, ask, does this match up?
Is what we're seeing make sense? So here you can see RNA scope on the
left. It was a sequential section to our 10x Visium spatial
transcriptomics, where we could map our microbial reads directly back
to these capture spots based upon our spatial barcode, which
acts like an area code. And as you know, this UMI is a proxy for
transcriptional load. So it gave us an indication of the different taxa that
were localized to the tumor tissue.
We saw they mostly co-occurred together in very specific regions.
What we typically see is that they infiltrate from the luminal region of the
tissue into the tumor, and that's where the highest density is
localized. But in addition to Fusobacterium, we saw Bacteroides,
Leptotrichia, Gemella, Compylobacter.
Often, our Compylobacter is concisus and ureticicus.
But this really confirms that these microbes have a heterogeneous distribution
within tumor tissue, and it's not just a single taxa.
They're communities that are infiltrating the tissue and coexisting
together. But what are they doing once they get into the tissue?
And that's, again, the key questions we're trying to figure out.
And to get some insight into this, we applied another spatial profiling approach.
This time we used Geomix. And we looked at
antibodies. We looked at a 77-panel antibody, and I think now there's over
1,000 different antibodies you can look at, so the technology has just soared
ahead. But when we applied this approach, we again carried out RNA
scope, and we assessed regions that were positive for bacteria
versus regions that were negative for bacteria.
And we looked at immune cell functions and also epithelial cell functions.
And what we saw was that these microbes, they were localized to immunosuppressive
regions. So these were regions that were characterized by myeloid cell
infiltration. We saw arginase 1, we saw CD66B.
We saw a reduction in T cells, so less CD4, CD8, CD3 T
cells, but we saw an increase in checkpoints, so
CTLA4, PD1, LAG3, VISTA. And we also saw an
upregulation of MAP kinases such as Fosl APK,
Phospho-p38. So they had very distinct
functional features, the regions that were colonized by these microbes.
This makes sense.
But this was all correlative at a period of time.
It didn't tell us whether or not these microbes were actively modulating their
infected tumor niche or whether they were colonizing a
preexisting environment. So in order to figure this out, we
always have to go back to the lab. We usually start with the patient, and then
we try to model what we're seeing in the patient back in the lab.
And here I'm showing you co-culture experiments with a clinical isolate
of Fusobacterium nucleatum. And I'm using the sensu
latu
for Fusobacterium nucleatum, just out of ease, but this is a subspecies animalis
that we had cultured from a patient's colorectal tumor.
So on the left, you can see cancer cell spheroids co-cultured with neutrophils that
are pink without Fusobacterium. And on the right, we have added our clinical
isolate of Fusobacterium. And what you can appreciate is that in the presence of
Fusobacterium, these neutrophils migrate into the center of the spheroid.
They form these large aggregates, and they become trapped.
So resembling this myeloid cell recruitment that we see in the patient tumor
tissue, and this is not surprising.
The cancer epithelial cells, they're producing
CXCL8. They're just screaming out for neutrophils to come
in and to attack the bacteria or remove the bacteria.
And what about the epithelial cells?
So here I'm going to show you cancer cell spheroids in green.
On the left, no bacteria, and on the right, we've added again our clinical
isolate of Fusobacterium nucleatum, which is seen in pink.
So without bacteria, we see the cancer epithelial cells. They grow en masse.
The entire spheroid enlarges. But when Fusobacterium is present, we
see migration occurring at the single-cell level, and it's
bringing Fusobacterium with it. And we also saw upregulation of
MAP kinases in a dose-dependent manner in the presence of
Fusobacterium. And additionally, we've carried out single-cell sequencing here,
so we can see alterations in epithelial, mesenchymal transition,
and extracellular matrix remodeling.
But single-cell sequencing,
it was very beneficial for our initial study, and we developed a
tool called InvadeSeq, but the challenge there was you lose spatial biology.
And as I mentioned, tools have moved forward dramatically.
So now we have the ability to look at single cells and even
subcellular-level resolution spatially, directly within patient
specimens. So the next part of the talk is the question that
we had is whether these microbes functionally impacted the tumor
microenvironment at the single cellspatial level.
So as you can see here on the left, we can see Fusobacterium.
Not all of the Fusobacterium is directly within the tumor
cells, in the cells in the tumor microenvironment.
On the right, you can see confocal microscopy of a co-culture, and this is the
center of a Z stock. So yes, indeed, there are cells that are
intracellular, but also there is bacteria on the outside of the
cells. So we really wanted to assess spatially the difference
between extracellular bacteria, intracellular bacteria, and how does
load matter when we start thinking about remodeling the tumor
microenvironment. And this was work that was led by Jorge Nino,
Falk Ponnett, and Javier Gomez in my group.
So we can apply spatial biology tools, AI tools such as Visium,
where we can now quantify the bacterial signals externally outside
of the cell and the cell associated.
And when we applied this to patient specimens, what we could
measure was the microbial counts outside of the cell
versus the total multiplicity of infection.
And what we observed is that most of the bacterial signals in
these colorectal tumors are actually extracellular.
So it's extracellular bacteria within the tumor microenvironment.
We applied this to a range of patient cohorts, including oral cancers or
colorectal cancer patient cohorts, and even a mouse model for colorectal cancer,
where you can see Fusobacterium as red and new bacteria in cyan.
And what we see is that as bacterial load increases,
we have an increased distance between the human
cells within that tumor microenvironment.
So these microbes are disrupting cellular
interactions within the tumor microenvironment based upon their physical
entity, and this is something I'll show again in a moment.
So we can measure the distances between the cells, and we can also measure the
densities in the regions where these microbes are localized.
This disruption of cell-to-cell interactions, it has a consequence, and here
I'm showing you a protein analysis through immunohistochemistry.
What we see in these regions with the highest density of bacteria is actually a
reduction in Ki-67, so lower levels of proliferation.
And when we saw this, initially, we were really surprised because most of the
literature centering on Fusobacterium will tell you that it induces
hyperproliferation of cancer epithelial cells.
But we did not see that, and we did not see that in our patients.
And we went back to the lab to assess that further.
And here you can see
cells that were with LifeAct, we have no bacteria on the
left, and we have Fusobacterium exposed on the right.
And what you can monitor over time is proliferation, and you can
monitor cell-to-cell interactions.
So
with high density exposure to Fusobacterium, we do not
see an increase in cancer epithelial cell proliferation.
We see disruption of epithelial cell interactions.
The cells remain viable. We've assessed this through propidium iodide, but they are
not entering a hyperproliferation state as the field previously thought.
We wanted to gain more information on this, and we used a FOUGE construct to assess
cell cycle. So we can assess cells that are in different stages of cell cycle,
G0, G1, S, G2, and M. And on the
left, you will see zero multiplicity of infection. So this is our control.
And then we have an MOI of one, 10, and 100 Fusobacterium
to cancer epithelial cells. And what we see is
that starting from an MOI of 10 and up to 100, we
see significant cell cycle arrest in G0, G1.
At a MOI of one, the effect
is pretty minimal. We're not seeing increased proliferation in any
of these assays.
When we go back to patient specimens and map what is potentially
happening, we can use now COSMIC single-cell spatial
transcriptomics. So again, noting these orthogonal approaches.
On the left, we have RNA scope. Fusobacterium is yellow, eu
bacteria is pink. And on the right, we have COSMIC single-cell spatial
transcriptomics, where we've designed bacterial probes.
And here I'm just showing you Fusobacterium and eu bacteria.
So you can see this really nice concordance between the localization of
bacteria through RNA scope and through COSMIC spatial
transcriptomics. Again, it's coming from this luminal region infiltrating into
the tissue. But with COSMIC, we can now identify the different cell types that are
present in the tumor. And this study was initially with the
1K gene expression panel, but now there's whole transcriptome
that has been released this year through COSMIC, so we can get even more
information on cell interactions.
You can also see that in the regions that are colonized by bacteria, there's a
reduction in the diversity of gene transcripts.
So these cells are still functioning.
They're producing transcripts, but at a far lower level than
regions deeper within the tumor tissue.
And we can carry out niche analysis within these tumors, and we can
identify the niches where these microbes are localized and start comparing the
bacterial infected niche to niches that do not harbor bacteria.
And when we did this, there were several modules that we identified
associated with the bacterial niche.
We saw an increase in barrier disruption and adhesion loss, so a reduction
in Ep-CAM and cadherin. We also saw reduced antigen
presentation. So remembering that these cells have entered an arrest,
so metabolism is down, gene expression is down,
antigen presentation is down. They're essentially in a protected state from our
immune system.
And the second module that we saw was an increase in stress and remodeling.
We saw upregulation of STATs, CXCL8 again, and
metalloproteases.
And then this functional consequence is a reduction in the diversity of the
transcripts per cell, increased cellular spacing between our epithelial
cells, a reduction in proliferation.
Again, we're seeing this reduced Ki-67 and overall this G0,
G1 cell cycle arrest.But the key question was: Is this a
reversible state? So what's distinguishing this from senescence versus
quiescence? And we did a range of in vitro and in vivo
studies to demonstrate that this actually is indeed reversible, that this is a
quiescence state that Fusobacterium induces.
Although I'm focusing on Fusobacterium here, we demonstrated this also with
Bacteroides fragilis, non-enterotoxigenic Bacteroides fragilis, and each
of the Fusobacterium nucleatum subspecies and sensu lato.
But the reason why this quiescence state is interesting, especially arrested in
G0/G1, is that most standard chemotherapies are
antimetabolites that act in S-phase.
So if you've got cancer epithelial cells arrested in G0 or G1, how does that
influence chemotherapy? So we showed that Fusobacterium
can induce resistance to antimetabolite 5-FU
based upon induction of this G0/G1 that is reversible upon
exposure. We also demonstrated this through analysis
of major pathological response, which was reduced in patients at a
higher burden of Fusobacterium nucleatum.
So in the last couple of minutes, I'm going to switch gears slightly because I've
talked primarily about how these microbes can influence the tumor
microenvironment, but this interaction is actually bidirectional.
The tumor microenvironment will also select for the types of
microbes that can survive and persist within
them. And this is a study that was carried out by
Martha Zepeda-Rivera, who was a postdoc between Chris Johnson's lab and my
lab. And this really centered on trying to understand were there particular
lineages of Fusobacterium nucleatum that were capable or had an
increased fitness to get to colorectal tumors and to survive and
persist within them. And this was a large-scale culturing effort that we had
carried out, where we assessed Fusobacterium strains
from patients with colorectal cancers.
We isolated over 50 unique Fusobacterium
nucleatum strains from patients and assessed
their genomics compared to oral
isolates from patients that did not have cancer.
And what we saw was that there is two groups, was one group
called FNA C1, and this was based upon its historical
16S gene profile, and FNA C2.
So it looked incredibly similar at the 16S level, but at the genomic level, they
were essentially different, what were subspecies.
What was interesting about this is that both were present at
relatively similar proportions in the oral cavity, but it was this FNA
C2 or F. animalis sensu
stricto that dominated the colorectal tumors.
Phylogenetically, they were each other's closest phylogenetic
neighbor, so genomically, the most similar within F.
nucleatum sensu lato. And when we looked at patient cohorts, we
saw that, yes, F. nucleatum was significantly enriched in tumor tissue
compared to normal. But when we broke this down, yes, the trend is there
for all of them, but it was really this clade 2,
or F. animalis sensu stricto, that was driving this enrichment of
Fusobacterium in colorectal tumor.
So this tells us that there is indeed functional selection, that it's not just
random colonization of tumors by microbes that are
passing from the oral cavity. And when we looked at
potential functions comparing this clade 1 to this clade 2, because they
are each other's closest phylogenetic neighbor, we saw that the clade
2 had the ability to resist acid in the stomach as a
potential mechanism for GI tract transit.
So it had a GAD system that allowed it to
metabolize glutamate and
produce GABA and facilitate this enrichment in the colorectal tumor.
It also had operons for ethanolamine utilization,
which resembles more enteric pathogens rather than traditional
oral microbes.
And I did want to highlight beautiful work from Cindy Sears' group,
again, with Julia Drews and with Dr.
Crean, where they demonstrated that there are biofilms, again, across the
colorectal tumors and that these
invasive
biofilms harbor Fusobacterium nucleatum and predominantly this
clade 2 Fusobacterium nucleatum or the F.
animalis sensu stricto.
Again, just highlighting some work from MD Anderson, and this is a study that's
led by Mike White, who's now currently carrying out a clinical trial looking at
metronidazole and combining it with standard treatments for patients
with rectal adenocarcinoma that are undergoing neoadjuvant
therapy. So assessing whether modulating the microbiome and the
tumor microbiome, in particular Fusobacterium and co-occurring anaerobes,
will impact patients' response to standard treatments.
And with that, just finishing on where our field previously was.
We were interested in the presence of these microbes correlating, but our
current understanding is that they are active drivers in modulating
tumor biology and impacting patient treatment responses,
impacting heterogeneity, impacting it from a polymicrobial
ecosystem perspective,
and also signaling molecules, metabolites that are altering the
functions of these cells. Where this field is going, I think we can
apply a range of new emerging technologies to understand this in more
detail. Things even relating from lineage tracing to
understand from a clonality perspective how these microbes can
contribute to metastases or recurrence.
Building on spatial biology and 3D mapping, we can start to
understand host microbe interactions in more precise
and intricate detail than we ever have before.
And the ultimate goal is to bring this to the clinic and understand how we
can help patients. So with that, I'll finish thanking patients who
have contributed to this research, along with my collaborators and my
funding sources. And thank you for your
attention.And
I'd be happy to take questions, but we also can take questions, I think we have
time now to sit together if we wanted to do that.
Yeah, we can start with questions-
Perfect
... on your
talk first.
Please.
Hi.
Very cool talk.
Thank you.
Based on the results that you showed, literature, and
we've also been working in my mentor's lab to look at
spatially identifying their bacteria, and two things that we see
is fusobacterium, like these obligatory
anaerobes, are primarily present on the
erosive surface and in perinecrotic or
necrotic areas.
Yes.
With immune cells and fibroblasts, they're not
necessarily directly in contact with tumor cells.
So two questions is, one,
with that distance,
how do we apply the findings
from the in vitro studies into the patient samples?
And the other thing is, I always wonder if it's the hypoxia of the erosive
surface and the-
Mm-hmm
... perinecrotic area-
Yes
... that is causing these tumor cells to just die off, and then they'll be farther
away. We do see that as you get closer to the necrosis, cells are
farther apart.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
How do we distinguish that correlation from causation?
Yeah. Absolutely. So right, again, these are anaerobic bacteria, so they love
necrotic regions of the tissue that tend to be hypoxic.
The one thing I will say is with spatial biology, especially if you're carrying out
transcriptomics, be very cautious because we know that this
microbe and other microbes in the tumor induce quiescence.
So when you have a quiescent state, you're going to have very low levels of
transcription. So you might mistake a cell
for being dead, but it's entered quiescence.
Proteins are a little bit more reliable with spatial proteomics.
But if you are carrying out transcriptomics, be very careful with that because that
is one of the major challenges here when you have a quiescent niche.
The other aspect of it is,
we do see them with cancer epithelial cells, and with the immune
cells in that environment.
So there's definitely interactions happening, but I think it's the
scale at which you're assessing it. Right?
Have you sufficient patient specimens to really make,
I suppose, a clear conclusion in what you're seeing, and is it
representative? Is that biology representative
across the specimens?
Susan, thank you for a great talk, as always.
Thank you.
I wanted to go back to something you mentioned earlier about the proliferation
conundrum that you were seeing, and I'm just curious, in your
mind, what do you think is the main difference driving
maybe this difference that we see in proliferation from your study and other
studies?
Yeah.
And maybe not just proliferation-
Yeah
... some of the other differences.
My initial thought,
based on the strains that we have is,
depending on you have patient strains versus the strains that people
typically use in some-
Yes
... of these studies.
Yes.
Do you think they've changed their phenotype to induce these different
behaviors?
Yeah, that's a great question, Leah.
All of what you're saying is possible, but what we've seen
is that if you just take bacteria and you put it
on a cell countess or a counter, it will count your bacteria.
Right? So if that's not included as a control, so if you've no epithelial cells and
you just have bacteria and you add that to a cell counter, it's counting
the bacteria. It will give you a quantitative metric.
If you're using an MTT assay or you're using a cell titre grow assay
and you just have bacteria, it will count the bacteria.
So if that isn't included as a control, it can
inflate the epithelial cell counts. Right?
So all of those assays are actually detecting bacteria as well, and many
of these microbes are clumping together, so they're being counted as cells.
So that is one possibility, and then, as you mentioned, there's different strains.
Fusobacterium is incredibly heterogeneous at a genomic level.
And yeah, I will say though, we have assessed ATCC strains, and we have
not seen an increased proliferation, and some of these studies use an MOI of 500
and 1,000, and at that stage, the
epithelial cells are just conked.
There's no increased proliferation, and we're using live cell imaging.
I would warmly welcome anyone to come and show me that it does increase
proliferation. We have not been able to reproduce that.
Thanks.
Thanks for the great talk. I was just curious if you could help me understand
how many of the specific effects of the tumor cells around
bacteria are versus Fusobacterium
nucleatum are--
That's poorly worded. But how many of those are
Fusobacterium-specific effects versus neutrophils just coming in because
there's some bacteria in there?
In patients, it's very difficult to assess that, right?
So model systems are where we can go looking at temporal
expression levels and looking at things like, there's this beautiful universal
lipstick model where we can start having antigen-donor
interactions and start assessing does it need to physically touch
Fusobacterium in order to have the phenotype.
In patients, it's really hard to tease that apart.
And what I would say is that from looking at my patient specimens, it
doesn't really care too much about who the
microbe is. But in saying that, only a certain
type of microbe can infiltrate the tumor.
So when the microbe enters the tumor tissue, we're still seeing
that neutrophil macrophage recruitment, because that's how
they're wired.
So it's kind of a chicken or an egg. The tumor is selecting for a
certain type of microbes, oral pathogens.
Perhaps they're responding because they have a similar phenotypic function.
So we're trying to tease that apart with spatial biology, but it's a good question.
I don't have an answer to it yet.
Really awesome talk. I think you've done a fantastic job of characterizing the
transcriptional state of the Fusobacterium niche.
And I'm kind of wondering, this very provocative result, I
think the lack of proliferation that you see.
In fact, it's not even just a lack of proliferation.
You're seeing those cells are going into a rest, right?
Yeah.
And this is sort of consistent with what our lab has seen,
too.What implications do you think it has for understanding of
Fusobacterium in tumor development and progression?
Right.
Like,
the duration of colonization, and then I guess,
potentially related to that is, have you looked at the regions that
are adjacent to the Fusobacterium colonized regions to see-
Yes
... what they're doing?
Yes.
What the transcriptional state there is.
Yeah. All great questions. And relating to the impact of
Fusobacterium on progression,
I think it can help explain some of that epidemiological data that has been around
for the past decade. Patients harboring high levels of Fusobacterium,
they have poor prognosis after chemoradiotherapy.
So all you need are a handful of cells to survive
chemoradiotherapy for those then to go on, these dormant cells, these
quiescent cells, to then go on and lead to recurrence or
metastases. We've also shown that these quiescent cells, they
actually have increased migration and capabilities, and that fits in with what's
known in the field. There's this go or grow hypothesis, right?
So there's spatiotemporal exclusion between cell proliferation and
cell migration. So I think it all comes together from that
perspective.
And your second question was relating to?
The
adjacent regions.
The adjacent regions. Absolutely.
With spatial biology, we can tease that apart, looking at the niches, and we do see
differences. They're not quiescent.
They're responding to the increased rim.
We've a rim of myeloid cells that have infiltrated, and we're looking at things
like CAFs, we're looking at VEGF.
So we're still working on this, but there's absolutely localized
impacts based upon the bacterial presence.
Thank you.
And the final question.
Yeah. Hi, thank you very much. So one question is
the influx of neutrophils that you showed, very cool in
your movie, and macrophage and other myeloid
cells. Do you think there's a long-term implication for
the environment of the tumor-
Yeah
... induced by that sort of neutrophilia and-
Yes
... then the Cs in that?
Yeah. That's something I would love to figure out.
I think the major challenge with mouse models is that it's fine for
acute infections, but it's the chronicity.
How do we measure the chronicity and the feedback loops that have happened over
several years in a patient? We're getting a snapshot at
one period of time in a patient when we carry out spatial biology, and our mouse
models are early stages of acute infection
in a preexisting tumor. So it's something we're trying to figure out and
how we can do this temporally, better models.
I was talking to Lars earlier about non-human primate models that
naturally develop colorectal cancer and are colonized by
Fusobacterium. So we're actively trying to think about that, how to model
that chronicity.
It's a great question.
Okay. And one more, hopefully quick one.
So you
said there are these niches, Fusobacterium's responsible, but they're
heterogeneous, they're
groups of organisms, and also that these things show
up in metastases.
Yes.
But what's going on in the mets? Does the
ratio of intracellular to extracellular change?
Oh, yes. Yes. It's a whole other
environment there. There's orders of magnitude less
bacteria in the metastases. We could grow them from Fusobacterium from the
metastases, but there's orders of magnitude less.
Now we have an active study underway where we're trying to do spatial profiling and
of the paired primaries in the mets to really tease that apart.
The previous time we had analyzed were in archival FFP
specimens and really low levels of bacteria they are there.
So I think the jury is still out, but I would, based upon what I've seen
so far, orders of magnitude less, and I would say potentially important in
seeding that pre-metastatic niche,
helping the cancer epithelial cells migrate,
evade the immune system, especially if they're in this dormant quiescent state.
And as we know, dormancy can be retained for
several years, decades in distant organs.
And then what wakes them up? Maybe they can wake up because there's such low
levels of bacteria in the liver compared to the colon.
We see that when we remove Fusobacterium, the cancer cells reenter cell
cycle. So these are all things we have to test, but I think
fascinating to understand the link.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you.
Okay, if there's no further questions, then I want to thank
the presenters for their great presentations, of course.
And I want to thank you for your presence and lively discussions.
Thank you very much.